before they was frozen
relive the peak of disney animation
followed immediately by its downfall
the lion king revisit the original tale
of a royal heir whose parents die
prompting them to run away from their
kingdom then sing a song about letting
go of their worries
while things fall apart back home and
return to defeat an evil prince
i knew there was a reason i liked that
movie journey to pride rock
an animal kingdom with some incredibly
generous borders everything the light
touches
is our kingdom and its own version of
new jersey what about that shadowy place
must never go there simba where all of
its african animals talk like they're
british
good morning sir evil british it's to
die for latino que pasa jewish moms
so where you from gangster there ain't
no way i'm going in there
or cnn
witness the birth of lion king simba an
obnoxious know-it-all who rubs his
privilege in everyone's face
my dad just showed me the whole kingdom
and i'm gonna
rule it off watch as simba's life of
leisure is shattered by his evil uncle
a lion who was either named scar by
coincidence or he got stuck with a
really mean nickname
get ready for a g-rated movie filled
with domestic abuse
i'm ten times the king a child raised by
a same-sex couple
not that there's a problem with that and
the most traumatic death of a parent
since baby's mom got shot in the face
dad
we gotta go home
hakuna matata so let frozen go
and experience the best music of any
disney musical
ever with unforgettable songs like
they'll be careful what you wish for
song oh i just can't wait till that
the plotting evil stuff song so prepare
because i am the bad guy be prepared for
me to do
bad guy things the catchy song to
distract kids from the horrific death
they just saw
i went through
forget all that an african catchphrase
the slow jam
and the song that fools us into thinking
these animals live in harmony
know
is
story lion jafar bird sebastian
ren and stimpy ed edd and eddie doomy
eyes
dad vader and kimbo the white lion
seriously look it up the lion king
wait if mufasa and scar the only male
lions in the pride
then nala's dead is probably oh no
oh i just can't wait for you to click
that subscribe button
if you do you'll surely feel the love
tonight
big thanks to our friends at av bite for
helping us with the music
go subscribe and tell him mufasa sent
you and breaking bad fans please be sure
to check this exclusive father's day
greeting to walter white
from walt jr himself rj middy
hakuna matata here is sub zero
now plane zero alpha rita's escaped
recruit a team of teenagers with
attitude i have a stupid with an
ugly face and a big bud and my butt
smells and i like to kiss my own butt